going back to when you were growing up
and you were surrounded by the idea of
psychology and you probably were
groomed at a young age to notice little
different things in terms of people's
body language how much does that play
into
your taking that
into your art i don't know that i don't
know that my dad really taught me how to
do that
maybe indirectly somewhat but
i was always kind of an introverted kid
when i was young i think part of it was
just being growing up with a single mom
for early part of my childhood i was a
little bit shy and timid
and uh
but i still have you know i still had
the
constant observant nature that i always
have
and so
an introverted person with an observant
mind will pay attention how other people
are and watch their mannerisms and watch
how they are and watch
you know
the structure of the social environment
around them and get an understanding of
that
it was very tough for me actually
because i was always a younger person in
my classes
um i actually i think i skipped a grade
early on to it didn't go to kindergarten
because my mom was really diligent and
taught me how to read when i was like
four or something like that so i
i was
one year behind everybody
developmentally speaking and
age-wise
and
so i sort of hung back for a while and i
think just a lot of that
the way i was as a child i learned how
to just sort of people watch really in a
detailed way and
i also was in this program called scope
which i don't think is around anymore
but when i was in elementary school it
was uh it's like the gifted program
and they would teach you a little really
cool tricks about life that they don't
teach you in most classes
um
and that is that you can kind of make
your own rules like you can
you can think critically about
situations and make your own decisions
you don't have to just follow what
people tell you or believe everything
that's being said to you so
um i learned how to
provide an extra step in my thought
process
uh early on from these classes and
interaction with my my teacher there
ms walters was my teacher she actually
hit me up on facebook the other day and
was like
excited about my film that was pretty
cool
um
because she knew i was into films even
back then so
uh
yeah that class definitely taught me a
lot early on
in fact they taught me one they taught
me uh
how to make the most of certain
situations and how to how to
navigate through tough ones where
you know if you're maybe sometimes
you're not getting a bad grade because
you're necessarily a super bad student
but maybe your relationship with a
teacher is not right
there's other levels to
life than just what is on a piece of
paper or
what imdb says or anything like that
and so i learned how to understand that
early on
so
i guess that probably
contributed
quickly to my
i would watch a film with that mind
mindset and i would try to understand
what the director's choices were and i
watched terminator 2 which was like my
favorite movie for a long time but still
is one of my favorite movies i can watch
it a million times still love it
but i would watch it and i would try to
understand why he made that why james
cameron made the decision to shoot that
way why james cameron made the decision
to have the actor do this or that or
move the camera here or
what have you and when i was growing up
they didn't have behind the scenes dvd
documentaries that gave away all these
secrets
i had to figure it out for myself so it
was a little more challenging but it was
also something i retained a little more
i think it's just an internal film
knowledge from all the movies that i
watched i would try to
i knew i loved a certain scene so i
paused that scene i'd watch it frame by
frame i'd watch it 10 100 times
and i try to figure out why i like that
scene and i figured out
like as i grew up a little more and i
started to have a little more depth to
my thought besides just being an
elementary school kid that was looking
at his friends
i would
i would think even further you know in
an
easier
14 15 you start becoming a little more
aware of your world your your awareness
increases
and
i would watch scenes that i liked when i
was younger
with a new eye and i would go oh man
i get it this scene works because the
rest of the film works
like i would watch heat
right michael mann movie one of my
favorite films as well
there's that crazy gunfight bank robbery
scene and about i think somewhere in the
third act
and
it's insane and it's really really
intense and by the end of it i'm
breathing heavily when i watch it
but it doesn't work the same if i just
watch it by itself
if i watch it by itself it's very
impressive and it's really cool
but if i watch the entire film up to
that scene
i have all this knowledge in my head
fresh of who these characters are
what their motivations are what their
emotional state is right before the
sequence and then we're let loose
and all that stuff is carried with you
throughout the scene and that i realized
it
how important characters are early on
because i was noticing why i like
certain scenes it was not so much
because i thought it was executed well
which was very true and i would try to
emulate that early on that was like the
best i could do as a young filmmaker i
tried to emulate the things i liked but
in a very small way because you can't
really understand it when you're young
so i would try to like emulate shots and
emulate framing and emulate the way that
pacing was in the edit and all that
but i wasn't quite getting it and part
of it was obviously where i was like a
young kid and i didn't have great actors
and fantastic production designer great
equipment but part of it was also i
didn't quite understand that other part
of it until later once i started to
understand that i became more interested
in and how that was done
how important
uh
the actor is and making the character
come to life as well
so
all that stuff kind of compounds
you know when you're doing your own
homework i guess
when i was in college i would watch two
three movies a day even if i was just
doing homework and it was on the
background at least i would have it on
in the background i would look over
sometimes i could associate stuff i was
learning in class with a movie so
when i read some when i read about a
subject now and i remembered studying
for it in college i remember oh i was
watching that scene in die hard when i
was studying that part of
this topic
so i have associations now
movies like
i remember that i was watching this part
of this movie when i was taking that
test
or whatever and it helped me do better
my grades and stuff because i was
associating something i really enjoyed
with something i didn't wasn't
necessarily excited about at that age
but
that's what
i learned from i didn't go to film
school and was taught these things from
a teacher or professor i
did the work myself i i really spent a
lot of time when i was a kid watching
movies and just trying to learn from
them
later on dvd came out and they started
doing behind the scenes and
people were you know the magicians were
pulling the curtain back and showing how
they did some of the tricks so i was
excited about that because some of the
times i'd be right about how i predicted
that they would do things and some of
the times i'd be wrong so i'd make
adjustments to my thought process based
on that
and
and now i can watch a movie
um and
nine times out of ten i think i'm pretty
accurate about how when i try to figure
out how they did a certain thing
if it's done in camera sometimes it fits
cg or whatever
still
working on that aspect of my time i
don't really don't know how to do a lot
of that stuff yet i'm getting pretty
good at compositing but that's one of
the
things that i'm trying to develop a
little bit more of an ability in uh
because i feel like it'll help me as a
filmmaker to to have a knowledge of
visual effects a little bit
more in depth because then i can make
decisions on set with that knowledge
whereas up until now i've mostly been
just doing stuff on camera
and then the people watching yeah the
people watching it sounds like that
really shaped you early on
yeah yeah just i mean
just being a timid
quiet
kid for a long time
i wasn't the type of guy that would have
liked parties and tons of friends over i
had like one or two friends at a time
but they're really good friends like
friends i can fight it in so
uh
i think i've always been that way to a
certain extent i've been very like
um
careful in who i choose to be very close
and french friend friend like with me
that i share information with that are
like on a seriously
honest and deep level
um just because i
i have found that the people that you
spend your time on are the people you
know like just like i said before the
people you surround yourself with the
people you
put your time into are
you know that's the kind of stuff that
comes back to you as well
so if you're
i think that's what a lot of young kids
get into the problem they hang around a
lot of kids that are doing like drugs
and all kinds of bad
what people consider bad things early on
it's hard to get out of that after
a while and next thing you know you're
30 and
not much has happened for you you know
it's a sad thing but i don't think
people will maybe realize that how
important
everything you spend your time on will
eventually spend its time on you so i
mean that's excellent because i think
also too even if it's not
the negative the drugs and and maybe you
know crime whatever also just the social
crowd and then always hanging out and
then you're never yeah there's something
like this it takes effort to go
socialize with people like yeah that's
how i look at it unfortunately
maybe that's just weird to me but i i
look at going to a party just for the
sake of going to a party as being like
tedious and
taking time like valuable time away from
what i could possibly
be doing otherwise to
to work towards making you know impact
some people might look at that as me
being a real big debbie downer but
i don't really care honestly because
it's worked for me up to this point and
i have a couple friends who have the
same philosophy and they're doing really
well for themselves right now so
it to me
it's something that has worked for me
everybody has their own way of doing
things but for me that's been my my
mentality seems to be going pretty well